second question today hey David does
Trump win by making the squad the face
or faces of the Democratic Party I
actually disagree with the premise of
the question I don't believe that Donald
Trump is making those four ethnic
minority congresswoman that he attacked
which such xenophobic ideas as they
should go back to their original
countries they still have relatively low
name recognition nationally outside of
their districts and it's really I know
it's hard for people who do politics
every week like we do or people who
follow politics like many of you in the
audience to understand this these four
Congress women are not very well known
to the American public
my guess is aoc is more well known than
the others certainly but outside of
political circles these are still
individuals who have relatively low name
recognition or face recognition they're
also you know that we've talked about
the popularity thing they're not hugely
popular they're not unpopular
particularly the way Donald Trump tried
to make them seem on the basis of
polling of non-college educated White's
big shocker non-college educated whites
don't love Alexandria Castillo Cortez
Elano Mariana Presley and the fourth one
Rashidah Talib but they're not
particularly unpopular or particularly
popular is the truth and what you also
have to understand is that Donald
Trump's approval is is highest it does
best when he's altogether silent and
these four members of Congress are
keeping Donald Trump fired up they are
keeping him going nuts they are
continuing to push him to put just
ridiculous things on Twitter that yes
his own base is probably unaffected by
but independents and people who are sort
of influence in influenceable reachable
don't particularly like it when Donald
Trump goes on these tirade specifically
attacking people so what Trump wins is
not let me step back this doesn't mean
that focusing on these four Democratic
Congress women isn't good for Trump in
other ways okay
I just disagree that he's making them
the face of the Democratic Party the
wind for Trump in calling these four
women out in talking about them and
focusing on them is that he helps to
divide the left and when you play up
those divisions when you make those
divisions appear bigger than they are
that is why we need to be careful about
this because that is not good for the
Democratic Party
Trump appearing to take a side in the
squad versus Nancy Pelosi to the extent
that that's even really a thing it's
good for Trump it's bad for Democrats
any political capital time and media
time that between now and November of
2020 is spent on internal fighting
within the left is good for Trump and
this is why I said at the beginning of
the week on the topic of impeachment
Democrats need to just agree we're not
going to do an impeachment inquiry and
we're not going to talk about it anymore
or we're going to do one in like six
months because that's when it will be
most damaging to Donald Trump or we're
going to do one right now and they need
to actually say out loud if we keep
doing this publicly where I say I want
an inquiry and you say you don't and you
say you do and the media cycle continues
this is not good for our chances to
remove Donald Trump in November of 2020
that is how Trump wins by playing up the
squad controversy he's not really making
them the face of the Democratic Party
and these are still relative unknowns to
non political average Joe and Jane Doe
Joe and Jane Schmo in the dough implies
I think that they're dead Joe not dough
in the United States if you disagree
with me change my mind